ich möchte ihnen einmal zeigen und sie
haben es wahrscheinlich selbst gesehen
wie es heute und gestern in den städten
aussah da gab es tolle bilder man hat
sich sogar ein bisschen fast im frühling
geführt hier sehen wir die isa voll in
münchen am wochenende die menschen haben
es genossen und für einen moment
wahrscheinlich corona vergessen auch in
berlin war viel los auf den straßen
er klingt bei wenn sie die bilder sehen
und sie waren vielleicht auch draußen am
wochenende wenn das wetter draußen
besser wird dann scheint den menschen
corona langsam egal zu werden oder
ich glaube nicht daran dass den menschen
krone egal ist und wir müssen doch auch
festhalten
seit zwölf monaten machen 99 prozent der
menschen in diesem land ganz viel mit
was die politik sagt und wo die politik
darum bittet also ich glaube nicht dass
es eine egal haltung ist aber natürlich
freut man sich doch nach monaten oder
nacht nach tagen jetzt auch dies kalt
war die man zuhause festigen dass jetzt
die sonnenstrahlen da sondern alle
rausgehen das halte ich für absolut
verständlich und trotzdem konnte ich
beobachten da wo ich draußen war man
hält sich auch an abstände wenn man
passt aufeinander auf also das sind
keine sachen die gegensätzlich sind das
leute draußen sind und dass man sich
weiter an die regeln hält aber es geht
doch um politische verantwortung und die
liegt jetzt drin dass wir klar sagen ab
ins ident von 35 ab entwicklungen die
positiv sind kann man wieder aufmachen
kann man kulturelles leben öffentliches
leben zu erklären wir werden uns die
inhalte anschauen und wenn wir uns die
inzidenz und anschauen dann werden wir
die 35 ja eigentlich nie erreichen und
wir wissen ja alle dass diese instanzen
eigentlich ein künstlicher wert sind wo
es sozusagen um die vermeintliche
überlastung geht und die
zurückverfolgung eben von den
gesundheitsämtern warum krallen sie sich
da an den 35 fest wenn sie jetzt schon
sehen dass die werte doch massiv wieder
steigen werden wahrscheinlich gerade
wenn dann menschen eben unterwegs sind
draußen sind wir sehen ja auch schon den
letzten tagen die zahl geht leicht
wieder nach oben wenn sie jetzt wieder
mit der 35 kommen dann nehmen sie den
menschen doch je weniger hoffnung also
erstmal sind das ja die zahlen die leute
infektionsschutzgesetz das beschlossen
wurde vom parlament das auch noch mal
bestätigt wurde in regierung wo die
union mit dabei ist wo die fdp mit dabei
ist es ist ja das was politisch
entschieden ist
und es geht ja um mehr als instanzen es
geht doch um die frage und belegung der
intensivbetten es geht für mich um die
frage auch wie stark ist eigentlich die
impfquote in diesem land es geht um die
frage testen wo wir ja ich wollte gute
ideen er kostet kann und sagen diät
coach ist schlecht wie auch in den in
den letzten wochen will sehen die bilder
aus israel wo die menschen bei der bar
sitzen und dann geimpft werden da gibt
es noch ein bier und schott dazu und
hier sehen wir das noch einmal wie das
in israel funktioniert und wie zufrieden
die menschen sind und hier wird
angestoßen mit einem bier auf den bayern
tech impfstoff der da verimpft wurde und
israel wird jetzt wieder alles auf
machen